♪ ♪
- Hey, what's going on,
everyone?
We're here back
at Hickory, North Carolina,
back at the home forge.
Let me show you around.
So here on this rack we've
got plenty of extra materials.
We've got some leather stuff,
leather carving tools.
Of course some extra belts.
We've got an overflow
of some Micarta
handle material.
And that's not all.
Things just getting started.
The saw blade is actually
a pretty cool story.
They're typically made of,
like, L6 which is
a pretty good carbon steel,
but the guy I bought it from
had it in a pawn shop
and was gonna paint
a mural on it.
I said, "Heck no. I'm gonna
put it to some good use."
So here it is making plenty
of chef's knives later,
and it's a keeper,
that's for sure.
♪ ♪
- Hi, I'm Matt Dairy,
and welcome to my shop.
Here is probably the second
most important tool
in the shop.
This is my belt grinder.
This is my hammer collection.
When I was young,
I had a weekend job working
for a tool collection,
and they paid me in hammers.
Probably the most important
tool in my shop--
this is my power hammer.
'Cause I'm kind of old
and I don't have
[deep voice]
gigantic arms.
This is my homemade forge.
Gets really hot,
so that's great.
This is my 365-pound
Sawyer's anvil
from France
that I just could not resist.
I am an anvil-holic.
This is my heat-treat setup.
I'm red/green colorblind,
so I love to use kilns
because that way
I don't have to judge
red in the blades.
- Next, I've got plenty
of steel to work with.
1080 and even 5160.
We've got 1075 here.
We've even got some 440
which is good
for a stainless San Mai.
Got plenty
of handle materials here
as well as Kydex
for some quick sheaths,
things like that.
We've got all the way
from burl blocks here
all the way to some
of Micarta
and even some liners as well.
This is the drilling section
where I keep
the drill bits,
our drill press,
and, you know, you gotta have
holes in your knife
to hold on the handle scales.
I have a variety
of respirators.
We got the drill press.
We've got some rivets
and some eyelets
for the Kydex sheaths.
Pretty much the general things
that you would drill holes for
is right here
at this workstation.
- These are
my hot-blade gloves.
I can hold blades up
to--theoretically
up to about 1,000 degrees,
but I usually won't hold
anything over 600 degrees
for more than a few seconds.
There's my spear
from the last episode.
Figured that was the right way
to hang it.
It's part of history now.
That's an old Russian poster
uh, telling people
not to drink.
That's actually
my cat skeleton.
My dad was a biologist
at Wesleyan University.
So that's my shop here
in Middlefield.
It's my happy place.